you just finished watching Ahsoka and
you're curious about the future of the
Star Wars franchise well look no further
than Dave felon's upcoming Standalone
Star Wars film rumored to be titled heir
to the Empire Star Wars heir to the
Empire is a novel by Timothy zhan that
was published in 1991 it was one of the
first Star Wars spin-off books to be
released following many others and a
long running Marvel comic series The
Empire is still around but not as strong
as before and that becomes clear when
Grand Admiral Thon resurfaces and starts
to rebuild his army using a mix of
secret Imperial technology and old Clone
Wars era Fleet and his own brilliant
tactics thraw manages to overthrow the
new Republic the Dave filon team is
already working on a movie set in this
time period as we've seen the Galaxy
during the Mandalorian and Ahsoka is
very similar to air to the Empire
everything these shows have been
exploring from the tragic fate of
Mandalore to ahsoka's hunt for Thon and
Ezra Bridger is meant to pay off in one
big screen Adventure it was announced
during Star Wars celebration that Dave
filon would be directing a new feature
film that would be the end of all the
storyline set up by the Mandalorian the
book of OBA Fett and Ahsoka